Istilah teleportasi kuantum mungkin kedengaran macam bahan cerita sains fiksyen, tapi macam yang kita akan bincang dalam episod
Qiskit in the Classroom harini, ia adalah teknik yang sangat nyata dan sangat berguna untuk komunikasi dan
rangkaian kuantum. Selamat datang ke Qiskit in the classroom. Dalam siri ni kita guna Qiskit untuk terokai konsep asas
yang selalu dicakup dalam kursus berkaitan quantum computing. Setiap video ada modul interaktif
yang dilink dalam deskripsi bawah, so pastikan korang tengok. Teleportasi memang dah jadi trope sains fiksyen dan fantasi
pada ketika ni. Seseorang atau objek hilang dari satu lokasi dan segera muncul di tempat lain.
Sebestnya ni pun tak bisa, malangnya jenis teleportasi ini sekurang-kurangnya memang mustahil. Ia akan melanggar had kosmik
laju. Tiada apa-apa yang boleh bergerak lebih laju daripada cahaya. Tapi teleportasi kuantum adalah
mungkin. Dalam teleportasi kuantum, maklumat bukannya jirim boleh dihantar antara dua
lokasi yang jauh. Yang diperlukan hanyalah sepasang zarah yang terjerat — satu di setiap tapak — dan cara untuk sampaikan
maklumat klasik antara dua tapak tu. Protokol ni dibangunkan pada tahun 1993 oleh sekumpulan
saintis kuantum termasuk Charles Bennett dari IBM. Diorang panggil ia teleportasi kuantum sebab sama macam versi
sains fiksyen, maklumat kuantum hilang dari satu lokasi dan muncul di lokasi jauh yang lain
tanpa pernah bergerak melalui ruang antaranya. Mungkin kedengaran macam sihir, tapi macam yang kita akan nampak, tak ada apa-apa
yang misteri atau ghaib padanya. Ia dibolehkan oleh fenomena keterjeratan kuantum bersama-sama dengan
komunikasi klasik. Harini kita akan lalui protokol teleportasi kuantum dan cara ia berfungsi. Kemudian kita akan praktikkan
ia pada komputer kuantum sebenar untuk teleportkan keadaan qubit dari satu sisi pemproses kuantum IBM ke
sisi yang lain. So ni macam mana teleportasi kuantum berfungsi. Katakanlah kita ada dua orang Alice dan Bob yang dipisahkan
oleh jarak yang jauh. Katakanlah Alice ada qubit. Kita panggil qubit Q untuk senang. Dan ia dalam suatu
keadaan kuantum yang tidak diketahui sq di mana alpha 0 dan alpha 1 adalah nombor kompleks.
Alice nak hantar keadaan dia kepada Bob, tapi dia tak ada cara nak hantar qubit itu sendiri. Mungkin Bob
terlalu jauh, atau mungkin Alice pun tak tahu tepat-tepat di mana Bob berada, so dia tak tahu ke mana nak hantar. Nasib baik,
kawan-kawan ni dah berkongsi sepasang qubit yang terjerat A dan B, di mana Alice ada qubit A dan Bob ada qubit B. Dan
qubit-qubit ni terjerat. Yang dimaksudkan dengan terjerat, walaupun dua qubit tu dipisahkan oleh jarak yang besar,
keadaan diorang dikaitkan dengan cara yang fizik klasik tak boleh terangkan. Pasangan yang terjerat ini
dipanggil Ebit, yang boleh kita guna sebagai sumber dalam quantum computing dan komunikasi.
Dalam kes ni Alice boleh guna Ebit sebagai sumber untuk hantar maklumat kuantum dia kepada Bob. Untuk tengok macam mana, jom
mulakan dengan tulis keadaan gabungan ketiga-tiga qubit ni di mana aku dah susun qubit-qubit tu lebih kurang secara arbitrari
pada ketika ni, tapi susunan ni akan berguna bila kita jalankan eksperimen pada Qiskit. Dalam Qiskit, cara standard untuk
susun qubit ialah dari kanan ke kiri. So keadaan qubit sifar akan muncul di sebelah kanan.
Jom kembangkan keadaan sedikit dan tulis semula ia macam ni. Kemudian langkah pertama dalam protokol teleportasi kita ialah
Alice nak jeratan qubit data dia dengan separuh qubit Ebit dia menggunakan gate C knot. Gate C knot atau controlled-NOT
akan tukar keadaan satu qubit — qubit sasaran — bergantung pada keadaan qubit lain — qubit kawalan.
Kalau qubit kawalan dalam keadaan sifar, tiada apa yang berlaku pada sasaran. Dan kalau qubit kawalan dalam
keadaan satu, qubit sasaran akan dilipat. So dalam kes ni qubit data Alice Q akan jadi qubit kawalan dan
qubit Ebit A dia akan jadi qubit sasaran. So dua sebutan pertama tak berubah langsung oleh C knot tapi
dua sebutan terakhir berubah sebab qubit kawalan Q dalam keadaan satu. Kemudian Alice
kenakan gate Hadamard pada qubit data Q dia yang bawa keadaan 0 ke keadaan 1 per 2 dikali 0 tambah 1 dan keadaan 1 ke
1 per 2 dikali 0 tolak 1. Aku akan skip algebra mudah kat sini yang korang boleh cuba isi sendiri kalau nak.
Tapi selepas susun semula beberapa sebutan korang akan dapat keadaan yang nampak macam ni. So sekarang keadaan terjerat tiga qubit Alice dan Bob
nampak macam tunggang-terbalik. Tapi tengok apa yang berlaku kalau Alice ukur kedua-dua qubit dia. Keadaan tiga
qubit akan runtuh separa kepada salah satu daripada empat
sebutan ni. Dan dalam setiap kes, Bob akan tinggal dengan keadaan superposisi dengan amplitud yang berkaitan dengan keadaan awal Alice yang tidak diketahui.
Ingat amplitud-amplitud itu ialah alpha 0 dan alpha 1. So
contohnya kalau Alice ukur kedua-dua qubit sebagai sifar, keadaan Bob akan runtuh kepada sebutan ini — keadaan asal
yang Alice nak teleportkan. Tapi kalau Alice ukur sifar pada qubit A dan satu pada qubit Q, keadaan Bob
akan jadi yang ni. Keadaan ini boleh diubah kepada keadaan asal qubit Q kalau Bob
kenakan gate Z, yang akan lipat tanda ini kat sini. Tapi Bob tak akan tahu nak buat ni
sampai dia tahu apa yang Alice dah ukur. So langkah seterusnya dalam protokol ialah Alice hubungi Bob dan beritahu dia apa
dua ukurannya. Selepas dia tahu itu, dia akan tahu operasi mana nak buat pada qubit dia untuk jadikannya sepadan dengan
keadaan asal Alice. Ni jadual empat ukuran yang mungkin dan empat operasi yang mungkin yang Bob
kena buat pada qubit dia berdasarkan ukuran-ukuran tu. Bob mungkin kena buat gate Z, gate X, atau kedua-dua untuk
ubah qubit dia supaya sepadan dengan qubit asal Alice. Langkah terakhir ni — di mana Alice hubungi Bob — by the way, itulah sebab
teleportasi kuantum tidak melanggar kausaliti. Walaupun keadaan Bob segera runtuh bila Alice ukur
qubit dia, Bob tak boleh dapat apa-apa maklumat dari keadaan tu sampai Alice beritahu Bob apa yang dia ukur. Dan
panggilan tu dihadkan oleh laju cahaya. Kita baru lalui banyak matematik terperinci, so fakta yang luar biasa
bahawa kita baru je teleportkan maklumat kuantum mungkin dah terlepas pandang. Tapi ia memang sangat menakjubkan. Dengan guna
keterjeratan sebagai sumber, Alice boleh buat ukuran untuk hancurkan maklumat kuantum yang tersimpan padanya dan biar ia
muncul di lokasi jauh yang lain bersama Bob. Jarak ini boleh mencapai ratusan, malah ribuan kilometer. Yang lebih
menakjubkan lagi, protokol ni tak perlukan Alice tahu tepat-tepat di mana Bob berada. Selagi diorang berkongsi Ebit
dan boleh berkomunikasi secara klasik antara satu sama lain, teleportasi kuantum akan berfungsi. Sekarang jom tengok macam mana ia berfungsi
WEBVTT
dengan Qiskit dan teleportkan keadaan kuantum sebenar pada komputer kuantum.
Kita akan mulakan dengan tiga qubit — satu masing-masing untuk qubit data Q dan qubit A dan B yang akan buat Ebit tu. Kita
mulakan dengan cipta Ebit. Kita kenakan Hadamard pada qubit A lepas tu C knot
antara A dan B untuk cipta keadaan yang terjerat yang kita nak.
Kemudian kita sediakan qubit Q Alice dalam keadaan kuantum rawak dengan kenakan satuan rawak yang ditunjukkan oleh kotak berlabel
U ni. Kemudian datanglah teleportasi. Pertama C knot antara qubit Q dan A. Kemudian Hadamard pada
qubit Q. Kemudian ukuran-ukuran tu meruntuhkan separa keadaan supaya hanya qubit B Bob yang dalam superposisi.
Ni adalah ketika Alice akan hubungi Bob dan beritahu dia apa yang dia ukur. Kemudian Bob akan kenakan beberapa
gate bergantung pada ukuran-ukuran tu. Kotak berlabel merah ni menandakan gate bersyarat. Yang pertama bermakna
Bob kenakan gate X pada qubit dia kalau qubit A diukur sebagai satu. Dan
yang kedua bermakna dia akan kenakan gate Z juga kalau qubit Q diukur sebagai satu.
So sekarang Bob sepatutnya ada qubit dalam keadaan yang sama macam qubit Alice berada pada ketika ini selepas gate satuan tu.
Kalau segalanya berjalan mengikut rancangan, kita dah teleportkan keadaan kuantum. Tapi macam mana nak semak ni? Kita boleh jalankan
circuit yang sama tapi buat satu perubahan kecil.
Di sini kita dah tambah satuan lain di hujung sekali circuit yang dikenakan pada qubit Bob. Satuan ini ialah songsangan bagi
yang kita kenakan pada awal tadi pada qubit Alice. Alasannya ialah kalau gate pertama tu cipta keadaan kuantum yang kini dah
diteleportkan ke qubit Bob, maka gate ni patut buat ia balik, bawa qubit Bob kembali ke keadaan sifar.
Tapi sudah tentu ini membatalkan semua kerja keras kita untuk teleportkan keadaan tu. So kita tak nak buat ni
kalau kita betul-betul nak buat sesuatu dengan keadaan yang diteleportkan dan kalau ia betul-betul dalam keadaan kuantum yang tidak diketahui
kita tak akan boleh kenakan satuan untuk buat ia balik. Pun begitu, ini adalah semata-mata untuk tujuan diagnostik untuk pastikan
teleportasi berjaya. Kalau kita ukur qubit Bob berada dalam keadaan sifar, kita boleh yakin dengan munasabah
bahawa teleportasi berhasil. Sebaik sahaja kita pasti protokol kita berfungsi seperti yang dijangka, kita boleh buang
satuan terakhir tu dan buat sesuatu dengan keadaan yang diteleportkan. Tapi buat masa ni jom pastikan ia berfungsi. Jom
laksanakan circuit pada komputer kuantum. Kita boleh guna Qiskit primitive sampler untuk jalankan circuit ni
banyak kali dan kumpul statistik keputusan ukuran. Kalau kita teleportkan keadaan Alice kepada Bob dengan sempurna setiap
kali, Bob akan ukur qubit dia sebagai sifar setiap kali, tapi dengan hingar persekitaran dan ketidaksempurnaan dalam
gate-gate tu, kita boleh jangka akan ada beberapa kali di mana qubit Bob jadi satu. Tapi selagi kebanyakan
masa qubit Bob diukur sebagai sifar, kita boleh kata ia berjaya. Di sini kita ada histogram keputusan ukuran
ketiga-tiga qubit. Ukuran Bob ditunjukkan sebagai slot pertama setiap rentetan tiga bit. Seperti yang dijangka, empat
keputusan yang sepadan dengan bit dia sifar jauh lebih mungkin daripada empat yang lain. So kita berjaya
teleportkan keadaan kuantum. Tapi tengok berapa jauh kita teleportkan. Ni peta semua
qubit pada pemproses kuantum yang kita guna. Dan dalam eksperimen tu kita guna tiga qubit ni je.
Qubit Alice ada di sini dan qubit Bob ada di sini. So diorang hampir bersebelahan je. Kita boleh
capai benda yang sama dengan hanya kenakan beberapa gate swap, yang macam nama dia mencadangkan, cuma tukar keadaan kuantum
dua qubit jiran. Teleportasi kuantum berguna untuk hantar maklumat kuantum jarak jauh, dan
keadaan kuantum telah pun diteleportkan ratusan kilometer sebelum ni. Untuk eksperimen kita kat sini, kita dihadkan oleh
saiz cip, tapi kita boleh buat teleportasi tu lebih impressive sikit dengan teleportkan keadaan antara dua
qubit yang jauh pada komputer kuantum kita. So jom cuba. Ni rajah circuit baru kita. Ia nampak lebih
rumit sikit tapi tiada yang berubah secara asasnya kecuali sekarang Alice dan Bob cipta Ebit berkongsi mereka,
kemudian berpisah. Siri garisan dan X ni mewakili gate swap yang alihkan
keadaan Alice dan Bob dari satu qubit ke qubit yang lain. Alice bergerak ke atas ke qubit 1 dan
Bob bergerak ke bawah ke qubit 12. Kemudian Alice cipta keadaan rawak dia pada qubit 0 dengan
satuan ni. Ingat dia buat keadaan tu selepas dia dan Bob dah pun
berpisah. So Bob dah jauh darinya.
Kemudian protokol teleportasi berterusan macam sebelum dan Bob akhirnya dapat keadaan asal Alice selepas operasi
bersyarat dia. Kita kenakan gate satuan songsang dan kemudian semak bahawa qubit Bob
berada dalam keadaan sifar. Dan sekali lagi kita nampak bahawa kebanyakan masa qubit Bob didapati berada dalam keadaan sifar.
So teleportasi berjaya.
Kadar kejayaan tu tak setinggi bila Alice dan Bob bersebelahan. Semua gate swap tu
boleh jadi mahal dan menyebabkan Ebit merosot sikit. Teleportasi kuantum mungkin nampak macam sihir, tapi macam yang kita dah
nampak, semua yang diperlukan ialah keterjeratan, saluran komunikasi klasik, dan sedikit kepandaian. Cadangan asal 1993
yang kita dah bahas dalam video ni membentuk asas untuk protokol-protokol lain macam teleportasi gate kuantum
dan ia adalah ramuan penting untuk pengkomputeran dan komunikasi kuantum.
Dari segi eksperimen, saintis terus menolak sempadan teleportasi kuantum, malah berjaya menteleportkan
keadaan kuantum foton antara makmal di Bumi dan satelit 1,400 km
di atasnya. Dan menteleportkan keadaan kuantum melalui kabel internet klasik yang berhingar. Kalau korang nak teleportkan keadaan kuantum sendiri,
pergi ke modul teleportasi kuantum yang dilink dalam deskripsi bawah. Terima kasih kerana menonton
dan jumpa korang next time.